16 meses después del regreso al poder de
los talibanes en Afganistán los derechos
de las mujeres sufren otro duro revés
los talibanes anunciaron la prohibición
inmediata a las mujeres para acceder a
la educación superior la ONU se mostró
profundamente preocupada por la
radicalización de las políticas
talibanes a pesar de su promesa inicial
de moderación
es claramente otra promesa incumplida de
los talibanes y es difícil imaginar como
un país puede desarrollarse y puede
enfrentar los desafíos que tiene sin la
participación activa de las mujeres y
sin la educación de éstas
la situación de derechos básicos para
las mujeres afganas ya venía
deteriorándose y en algunas provincias
del Norte del país gobernadas por los
talibanes incluso antes de la toma de
kabul en agosto de 2021 el acceso a la
educación para la población femenina ya
estaba prohibido o limitado a la
enseñanza de religión y labores
domésticas además de restringir la
educación La abolición de derechos
políticos como la participación femenina
en cargos públicos y ministeriales es
una realidad las mujeres afganas tampoco
pueden acceder a la mayoría de empleos
que impliquen salir de sus domicilios y
el código de vestimenta ahora las obliga
a cubrir completamente su rostro
siguiendo las leyes de la sharia
el viraje radical de los talibanes puede
jugar en contra de las aspiraciones del
gobierno del emirato islámico de obtener
reconocimiento internacional
Estados Unidos ha declarado de forma
reiterativa que la legitimidad y el
apoyo que los talibanes buscan de la
comunidad internacional comienza con la
legitimidad que obtienen del pueblo
afgano a través de sus acciones
Estados Unidos podría barajar más
sanciones internacionales al gobierno
talibán las cuales según la ong acción
Contra el Hambre han provocado una
crisis humanitaria que afecta más del
92% de los afganos